what's up everyone welcome to a new vlog
I mean Iceland with Marcia and two
gnomes so the plan is to recreate my
last Iceland vlog footage by footage
sent by said he did you just ruin my
shot oh my god
Marcia have you met it work I'm gonna
Photoshop you away that was really good
this is why I'm here I'm here for the
fish soup right here last time we're
recreating everything basically it's the
fish got it
Jesus Christ are you okay Iceland so the
water is steaming which must mean that
it's high it is oh my I touch it it's
really nice basically the reason why
we're here is because I don't know we
just really liked it here it's such a
pretty place that we wanted to see it
again and experience some more different
things there's a lot of stuff to do
[Music]
the soup is coming happening
I'm so excited there it is oh yeah
this is what I'm talking about but one
food I missed from Sweden it's the fish
soup falling line mmm that's good
another thing I love about my son is
that they have the exact same sweets as
in Sweden I get all the stuff that I
missed the last goodies the hockey pull
very very nice that's the end of day one
I know that was practically nothing but
we have a long day tomorrow so we'll
have a ton of footage then see you
tomorrow
damn look at that we got snow boys we're
gonna be driving the Golden Circle today
so this should be interesting it's
snowing so much goddamn Swedish man
impressed by snow okay I've been living
in UK different Jeff Smith
you trying what are you doing Mario
tries to prove that we're I'm the one
causing us to be laying well you are
then explain this No oh I got sprinkles
beer it's Valentine's Day I need to be I
don't you guys remember
but huh Coleman a year ago Nene they had
a fear battle now he's gonna die
[Music]
Media wanted to come over here
we are at our first stop at the Golden
Circle it's a lake oh my god oh god I'm
scared
so pretty
[Music]
why don't you come out PJ I'm gonna push
you in the game sir PJ yeah yeah god
damn it's hot I dare you to swim PJ all
drinking right now damn look at all this
oh I smell it
god dammit smell come on guys is living
the moment oh it's bubbling no false
alarm Hey
what what are you kidding me god damn it
nice whoa oh hey you could totally see
that I missed it again damn it oh that
was awesome
well in a second what a surprise follow
us when you think the villain is dead
and he comes back so next up is the
waterfall
I think it's snowing I bought these very
nice Icelandic bathing suit because
tonight we're going to the Blue Lagoon
well what a nice view never mind we're
going to the waterfall and goddamn it
snowing whoa holy
God dad I've been here before I forgot
how cool it is
[Music]
it's Blue Lagoon time everyone very
exciting here we go we're entering the
stinky blue oh god the way it's not
closed door dude so pretty you see the
moon you see the Stars amazing we're
swimming through very nice I look crazy
we're back Blue Lagoon how is it amazing
I just sharted Wow you're marrying me
where it's at Valentine's Day
I really hate Matt's now we can see you
oh god damn that it's not a good list
Urgals the clown got it snowing and is
hitting my face so hard okay
some good old crap crap
we're walking back successfully
rejuvenated thank you Blue Lagoon once
again see you tomorrow bye
[Music]
so we've been driving to now showers I
don't know where we are but it's very
very pretty I had another fish soup
very nice and that we're getting close
to our destination I don't if you can
see so much it's kind of foggy but the
mountains here are crazy
everything is just so pretty and the
ocean is this right there and also more
importantly I prepared snow balls so
that when PJ comes out he's gonna get it
why'd you come over here hey Jake
no oh oh look at that
what's up horses I've gotten great shots
over here cool we got the horses we're
good to go
let's keep driving such a fiery little
home this road is crazy
we're its River actually in the middle
of nowhere oh I smell them or is that
you PJ Wow look at this you can't see
anything this is wine everywhere
goddamn
we have arrived in the middle of nowhere
and it's snowing I don't know about this
going to be honest it's a guy
it's a giant stone man this is very fun
poor man legs a thousand years of good
luck oh my god
I'm back in Sweden damn it's actually
ice here there's a bunch of cliffs like
down there so we're probably gonna walk
down and it's gonna be pretty cold and
snowy but it'll be worth it
whoa Dan look at these rocks whoa
there's caves in there that's where the
treasure is
what is that PlayStation game called TD
the treasure one Nathan Drake Nathan
Drake wants Uncharted this is uncharted
you're going there for the treasure look
at that bird don't jump don't do it man
eating worth of me
[Music]
and look at that rainbow boy all the way
double no this is one look at that whoa
holy this is amazing you got the ocean
you got the rainbow Oh God look at that
ice next to the cliff come on guys it's
safe you're gonna die Vidia I got you
Marcia the elves flow this view holy
look at that bird though I gotta say my
honor ain't it's a phenomenal camera
quality yep so we're here at the
Arrowhead mountain excuse me
we should probably seen at the Game of
Thrones stuff which I look how much you
can see it incredible there it is here
we are at the waterfall and Meg saying
where you go Mars yeah 20 points coming
right up I'm doing it wrong I'm doing it
right no let me show you you'll
regret this
[Laughter]
okay three I'll never trust you again PJ
don't you advise it you're dead to me
don't go too close Marty I know my Xena
[Music]
so next look at this look at the moon
look at the mountains
well goddamned I missed it it flew like
super-close we're back home everyone
it's the end of the vlog hope you guys
had fun it's much like subscribe and as
always have a great smile on your face
back to making videos to destroy
t-series once and for all
I bet you thought you could make a tea
series while I was away you sneaky snake
think again hello Oh me did you
you little crybaby where did you go I
bought your thing or after you cannot
rape me
bye